hey leute herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video und nach längerer zeit das könnte
eigentlich schon fast meine
standardgröße werden ich hab mir was du
isst überlegt vielleicht heute sebastian
hinter der kamera und ich habe mal
wieder mittlerweile ist das irgendwie so
ein bisschen so einen kern konzept von
einem kanal eine sache gut die wirklich
krass ist die ihr wahrscheinlich noch
nicht gesehen habe und die testen der
grund zwar sieht erstmal aus wie ganz
normales seifenblasen maschine es ist
aber eine seifenblasen maschine deren
seifenblasen man essen lecken wie auch
immer kann das krasse ist dabei ist und
so eine ganz normale flüssigkeit male in
die usa diese seiten lauge ist
einerseits essbar oder trinkbar und
andererseits kann man sie vermischen mit
verschiedenen sodass also cola fanta
sprite limonaden einfach deshalb habe
ich hier auch schon mal drei sachen
vorbereitet fastbreak nicola und die
werden wir heute testen indem sie mit
der seite waren lauge vermischen und
dann haben wir es bahre seifenblasen und
vielleicht sagst vielleicht wird das der
trend 2009 10 und sommer
ich habe dort mittlerweile die
verrücktesten sachen liebe augen gesehen
in meinem leben einfach weil ich sushi
komische sachen teste und dazu habe ich
noch dieses paket hier sind noch weitere
von diesen normalen flaschen drin mit
dem sich eine seiten blasen mischung mit
geschmack machen kann das ist so
wirklich zur hälfte gefüllt mit so einem
ding und die flüssigkeit ist wirklich
sehr dickflüssig im vergleich zu einer
normalen seifenblasen flüssigkeit mal
dieses jahr fast komplett finde ich
schon so ein bisschen schleimig was da
muss jetzt eine batterie ihre eine große
hat natürlich am starten weil ich bin
perfekt vorbereitet unsere seiten lassen
maschinen ist fertig kommen wir ob sie
auch funktioniert sehr gut wenn wir da
rein schaut das einfach so ein
schaumstoff propeller das tut man vorne
rein und dann werden die einfach
ausgepustet bestimmt ziemlich klar auf
dem ostring es schmeckt wie also ist
überhaupt kein geschmack von seife
eigentlich auch der falsche begriff aber
wir nehmen das erste ich würde sagen als
erstes weil irgendwie geld zu machen wir
mal am tag und dafür öffnen wir dieses
ding hier schreibt mir die kommentare
habt ihr doch schon mal getestet gibt es
das überhaupt in deutschland aber
vielleicht sind ja auch meinen zuschauer
irgendwie in amerika groß geworden oder
was auch immer
jetzt schaltete scheint das okay ich
habe es jetzt bis zum strich voll
gemacht nicht für das einfach mal so ein
bisschen proben mit der kelle hier
sollte man gucken ob sie überhaupt
funktioniert direkt nach man kann es
nicht wirklich direkt als auch private
probleme fangen mit den dingen alle
meine träume und das ist auch nicht der
fünf minuten bis ich gelernt habe wie
man seiten laden habe kurz geboren
ok krank war
nützliche der maschine ausprobieren
nur oder lkw mit nur sie wissen wir in
die luft schießen
er ist sehr viel sonne und du denkst oh
okay jetzt weiß ich irgendwo rein weil
es ist auch nicht zu erwarten ist dass
meine mode
[Musik]
da als aufdruck i was geschmeckt wie
schmeckt das ist schmeckt wirklich sowie
fantasie oder fahren oder wasser
[Musik]
ja was soll ich groß sagen es
funktioniert die seiten da sind
schmecken tatsächlich nach hunter
irgendwie es ist total verrückt ich
meine er überlegt sich sowas weil ich
bei meinen meisten video mittlerweile
ist das ist schlau was wir machen
so sind wir selbst nur ich komme dass
ein du musst auch mal probieren
die richterin hatte mit ist kraftlos
gefühlt sie irgendwie nicht ganz richtig
wir können jetzt richtig
[Musik]
einfach köstlich ok ich würde sagen wir
kommen hier noch schnell die andere
geschmäcker durch das ist direkt wie
cola probieren kann mit der normalen
lauge wurde einfach auch schon
seifenblasen machen kann es hat ewig
aber normal welche künstler cherry cola
ich habe es gar nicht gestellt sind bei
hellweger okay wir machen das feuer habe
harry das hat jetzt ja noch vier treffer
geschäumt oder wir müssen gucken ob das
genug schon ist der zitierte eine ahnung
sieht aus wie energy drink eigentlich er
war ja da spielt die bisschen ist ja
genau das war nicht hier eigentlich
müsste die kohle in der lage sein link
zu verfärben ach du meinst wenn ich die
gepustet ja genau das dass du so
farbigen hat dass sein vater frank dafür
wirklich krank machen ich glaube ich
glaube die politik schafft es
tatsächlich nicht
es ist ein bonbon ja ja keiner was
kuba ist am klarsten 4 2 führte
[Musik]
es ist ein sättigungsgefühl vieles mehr
was ist einfach nicht da
mitschnitte nicola seitengassen essen
ist wieso am ende des monats auf dem
konto schauen sollte eigentlich was tue
ich verstehe man weißt du mir als mensch
nicht so wirklich immer so ne cola blase
ist man möchte ja aber ich weiß was ich
wirklich nicht checken
für wen ist so was außer für youtube für
sehr gut frage oder sie zu wir haben das
musste ich das mit story kaufen denn man
mag sich morgens auch wächst jetzt wo
ist meine maschine für essbare seiten
lassen
gbp es gibt keine richtig muss torwinkel
also schon ich schon bisschen mehr farbe
ich muss jetzt nicht nutzen ich habe ja
auch gerade mal gewinnen ich hab das
auch so passt also ich bin selbst noch
nicht so in game ich werde aber
wahrscheinlich einen kanal aufmachen und
auf dem die saiten blasen tricks marke
yamaha kombis seien blasen reviews auf
wenn ihr das wollt lasst mal 100 live
scheibe durch kommentare wir wollen
okay mein gesamter körper klebt so war
der abend haare sind so ein bisschen am
leben und meine hände sowieso den boden
auch ich würde sagen ich können wir
jetzt überhaupt hier alles sauber zu
machen ihr habt heute die wir sehen wo
menschen essbare seiten davon treffen
fand ich das gut scherzte die kommentare
was kann ein leichter ich würde sagen
wenn ihr teils freiburg mit wein bier
nicht gute den verletzten diego wieder
statt
ich hoffe dass sie bald wieder neues
video hat dann bin ich vor sagt
vielleicht ein bisschen motivieren und
wir sehen uns dann alles gut und tschüss